i'm joined today by chris roser who is a
professor of production management to
Yoda and McKinsey alumni and interested
in the past present and future of
manufacturing he writes on his blog all
about lean dot-com and he just published
a book called faster better cheaper on
the history of manufacturing so Chris I
want to jump right in because there's so
much to talk about first let's talk a
little bit about your field in the
context of the presidential election
that we have here in the US we've heard
to varying degrees from Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump claims about bringing
jobs back manufacturing jobs from other
countries including China and Mexico of
course Donald Trump having sent some of
these jobs to those countries to begin
with but we'll ignore that for for the
time being my critique has been many of
these jobs no longer exist due to
technology and neither candidate is
really talking about that how big of an
issue is technology and automation in
the field of manufacturing right now
it's a very big issue civ Eric will come
back up not two drops eventually when we
have the automation and the robots to do
also work automated and of course East
Asia and a so-far of our countries have
known on our labor cost advantage so you
can manufacture in America too but it
won't be with people it will be mostly
this robots and very often when we think
about manufacturing and automation
people's minds go to factories with
robots instead of people but there's a
sort of further question that I want to
explore with you which is what about the
pre manufacturing portion which is the
engineering part right we I think for
many people it's harder to imagine that
the engineering part will be automated
but is that also in the future I believe
yes of course at that point we are
talking about opinions not facts because
it's a future but I believe it is the
future it will also be possible to
automate more complex and cognitive
demanding tasks like engineer
to me so human brain is a collection of
neurons and signals and it's nothing
that cannot be simulated or modeled with
a computer if the computer will be
powerful enough right now it's not yet
but in the coming decades I believe it
will about when exactly people have
different opinions some readers
researchers say 20 years as a saying 100
years against an associate member but I
believe at one point the computer will
be able to do pretty much everything
better than we do there are some tools
online that have started to pop up which
say you know enter your job and will
tell you how likely it is to be
automated or replaced by a machine or a
robot or a I in the future within the
broader areas of manufacturing what are
the least automatable jobs in your your
estimation saliste automatical jobs are
probably the drops which still wears the
customer puts value on interaction with
humans if the customer pays not for a
product but for something to talk to a
human being that's a job which will
probably remain non-automated for longer
and of course right now many troughs
which we have have was talking with
human beings that can be automated and
it's already are like call centers and
stuff like that is already heavily
automated but if you go for example to
up psychologist or something I'm not
sure if a computer would give the same
feeling as a machine but then maybe I'm
wrong can we expect um significant
changes to more environmentally
conscious or sustainable manufacturing
anytime soon and I'd also just want to
broadly ask you what would that even
mean to have more sustainable
manufacturing particularly when we think
about the Industrial Revolution being at
the sort of center of human-caused
climate change on the planet what would
it even mean to move towards
environmentally sustainable
manufacturing
when you say sustainable manufacturing
sorry three things that need to be
sustainable one is the environment the
second one is relations with the people
and the third one is the finances of the
company and in most cases many companies
already squeezed financially so so do
environmentally what is necessary so do
what will in the long run save some
money but few companies are doing a
trust out of the good of their hearts
say awesome but for many companies that
trust our cost value analysis to see
where to put in money to save
environment where they're forced to by
law and if they do it voluntarily said
probably often say spend more money on
advertising their good deeds and on the
good deed itself hmm so if we were to
I'll get into some more specific
questions in a second but if we were to
say subsidies aside and and sort of
government incentives aside generally
speaking in the world of manufacturing
is more sustainable manufacturing more
expensive typically that's a good
question it's it can balance out to plus
minus zero it depends on the exact case
in some cases when it actually saves
money safe done it long ago like um car
makers say save every piece of scrap of
metal and melt it down to make a recycle
it because it just makes sense
money-wise so in that respect
sustainability is already good business
sense and most people wouldn't really
call it economic electrically friendly
because it's just done anyway because it
saves money but other things that cost
more money are things which companies
are more hesitant and I believe it's a
task of politics and the customers and
the population channel to put the
pressure to motivate those companies to
become more environmentally friendly
right because very often when we think
in the u.s. I mean I think the carbon
tax is sort of an example where people
say the only way to really incentivize
more environmentally friendly behavior
is to artificially make it more
expensive to be economically unfair and
mentally unfriendly so to speak now what
the critics of that idea say is you're
not considering the costs of the
negative externalities of the uninvited
friendly or environmentally unfriendly
actions and i'm wondering i mean is is
this even something that we can really
fine-tune and deduce specifically from a
financial standpoint can we really
measure the external the negative
externalities of manufacturing in an
objective way or will there always be
disagreement about exactly what the
financial value there is as it's
difficult to measure the financial value
and the cost and also whenever you put
an external if there's an external
matching on it the companies also try to
avoid it or try to find a way out of it
and I'm not even talking about forex
large diesel gates that's a particular
case but imagine your company and and
you're into logging and you're kind of
dude putting a new forest kind of
proceeding new forest hmm even if
stances anyway but nowadays you probably
make a little bit money on the side by
selling it as a new tree as carbon
friendly even so it may not gross that
many additional trees but only it looks
better for the company which buys the
carbon rights from the trees that one
company is planting interesting last
thing i want to touch on a little bit
there I've read a few articles and there
admittedly not backed by the most
precise and extensive sort of data but
there have been a few articles i've read
which suggests that for the US
specifically the move towards automation
and robotics and artificial intelligence
may actually be good in the sense that
and you sort of alluded to this at the
beginning when you said when it's the
machines doing the work it's no longer
drastically cheaper to have the machines
do the work overseas than in the United
States and that there's a possibility
and I I have no idea whether the numbers
actually bear this out there's a
possibility that if you move all of the
machine all of the work back to machines
in the u.s. rather than people in Asia
and other parts of the world
old that you might actually bring some
ancillary jobs back to the United States
the maintenance of the machines for
example maybe some more of the
engineering would be brought in-house or
some more money would be freed up for
engineering and creative jobs because
the machines are now doing the work is
there anything to that idea or is it
really sort of unreasonable it's really
hard to get solid and reliable data
about those kind of things most models
are builded more than a wild guess in an
estimate but I believe in the medium
term it will increase the participation
of the workers or will provide more
drops for exactly the people you
mentioned for the people who maintain
install and build the robot there will
be more drops for some in the medium
term until of course in the long run
maybe 50 or 100 years and make it
automated true but in the medium term
but I think it will bring trops back to
America which otherwise would have never
come back absolutely fascinating i will
remind you the book is faster better
cheaper we've been speaking with the
book's author Chris roser who is a
professor of production management
thanks so much for talking to us about
this thanks David